who earns the minimum wage President
Obama's recently suggested raising the
federal Ali minimum wage from seven
twenty five to ten dollars ten cents the
congressional budget office estimates
that by late 2016 this would raise
900,000 people above the federal poverty
threshold and increased earnings for
low-wage workers by 31 billion dollars
but less than a fifth of that money
would actually go to families living
below the poverty threshold you see most
of the 1.6 million americans earning the
minimum wage don't actually belong to
what the Census Bureau defines as
low-income families in fact many of
those who may benefit from a higher
minimum wage don't fit low-wage
stereotypes at all according to analysis
from the Economic Policy Institute only
around one in 10 of those workers would
be affected are teenagers and flipping
burgers or otherwise the average age is
35 and more than a third of 40 or older
around fifty percent work full-time more
than a quarter have kids on average they
earn half their family's income and one
in 10 of graduated college this proposed
raise would mean that some low wage jobs
were eliminated and up to a million
people as a consequence could need the
workforce analysis subtract the income
that would be lost by high income
workers from the increased earnings for
low-wage workers and the net boost the
GDP will barely top two billion the
bean-counters employed by Congress may
have some good news for budget halts at
least the net effect on the federal
budget deficit would probably they say
be small at least in the short term